so when you look back at your incredible
career what do you think of in terms of
what you'd wish you'd spent more time on
less time on you know how some people
say you know I wish I'd worried less or
I wish I'd reached out to this person or
that person anything that you can think
of now that you think yeah I wish I'd
done less of this I wish I'd done less
whoever it was a mindset oh well yeah
certainly when I was it's not that I'm
not serious now but I was so serious
when I first started which is a good
thing but there were certain things that
I passed on because in my young mind it
wasn't serious enough and it was it was
a huge mistake because there was a great
experience there to be had it isn't
isn't always about the quintessential
part or anything like that so in that
way I wish that I had taken it just
slightly less seriously in terms of what
you'd wish maybe you've done more of
anything theater and and you know and
and hope to hope to do more theater I
wish I'd stayed I did some theater in
New York I wish I would have stayed to
do a little bit more before but I'm a
California girl it's hard I wanted to be
I wanted to be home so I came back and
you loved the ocean
I understand I love that you know I my
father raised me around the ocean and I
was scuba diving and by the time I was
10 you know I was fishing ever since I
could hold a pole and so I I lived in
Hawaii for a while and I've served for
25 years and scuba dive and all that
sort of things
yeah any analogy and surfing that
applies to navigating an acting career
Oh easily I love seeing all these people
now that you know they're all surfers
you know Matthew McConaughey but I
understand why I do because you can only
be in the moment it's like rock climbing
I used to be a rock climber as well you
can only be in the moment when you're
doing that or you're gonna get in you're
just gonna wipe out in not such a good
way and one has to feel the the motion
of the nature of the beast that you're
on and so yeah I learned a lot a lot
about endurance and and keeping my eyes
open certainly so going back to the time
that you were in American Graffiti
your motivation for continuing with
acting is it the same back then as it is
now
how do people mm-hmm I mean the the work
it was it was it was always about the
work I was raised in a really good you
know Mount Tamalpais high school Dan
Caldwell College of Marin where I met
Robin Williams and Harvey sesor and Jim
Dunn they they gave us great tools so
when I did I never promised you a rose
garden and I was pretty raw I didn't
have a lot of technique but yeah when I
was that age it was more like oh wow you
can you can tell a story I can express I
can touch people in a certain way I
didn't really realize that when I first
got into it do you you know so so that
was a realization that was a discovery
and how long did that take
in terms of come to that realization to
that realization pop well I certainly it
came with with I never promised you a
rose garden that came fast and hard in a
way that I was not prepared for but then
once it all settled in I went okay I
could I could do this this is and
there's a lot to be learned here and
that's the other thing I was not good in
school I tried like hell but I was not
good I was very dyslexic without knowing
yet I think a lot of actors are and it
was a great education for me you know
it's a great way to learn about
something and especially to express it
in a certain way it made it really stick
whatever it was that I was studying so
if you were to advise another actor
actress from the Bay Area mm-hmm I'm
coming to LA and I've heard you say
before that you know life has sped up so
much and I agree I think we're at too
fast of a pace and had a detriment to
all of us but what would you tell that
actor filmmaker that's coming from maybe
a place that's not as fast-paced as in
LA or New York in terms of their career
and staying in the moment when they have
everything yeah Twitter coming at you
you have YouTube comments you have
instant updates about whatever in your
Gmail god I don't know I don't know what
to tell him except that well first of
all lose the prejudice about LA or
Hollywood just lose it because it's here
you know there the filmmaking is
everywhere now it's here it's in New
Orleans it's in Atlanta it's in North
Carolina it's everywhere there is no
Hollywood anymore it's just an enigma
now so you can just forget all that
stuff and I was I was not very good
I'm still not very good at
self-promotion you know all the Facebook
and the Twitter you know all the younger
people are teaching me about that so I
would say if you can do anything get
somebody to help you with that so that's
not your focus so so all that stuff is
it's it's necessary mechanism but it's
shouldn't be your focus your focus
should be your work just do your work
and whatever happens from that and find
any way to do it like this idea that
everybody's going to come and be famous
is like ridiculous it's are you gonna
are you doing the work because you love
the work and you want to give something
then great then enjoy the hell out of it
and if you get to get a ride like I've
had them great enjoy it but no it's not
about an end result and lastly what
should oughta take away from the film
after your role of Nora Valentino and
the story and no we don't want to give
away the ending but in terms of a
message what would that message be wow
that's a good question
what should the audience take away from
after well of course whatever however it
speaks to them that's what would be
important to me I would hope that it
moves them in some way I would hope that
because it's a story about actual people
that they might be able to be a bit of a
voyeur and and peek in on something they
might feel or see and from the family
all these fad I hope they take away they
enjoy seeing stories about people
because that's what I thought we used to
go to the movies for to see stories
about ourselves or
people we love and and that everybody's
doing the best they can
that's all we can do it sometimes we see
a role of someone and we it's something
in ourselves as spark then by seeing
that betrayal something like right yeah
yeah I hope that I hope that they're
moved in some way that they can
understand someone's human frailty and
fragility the fragility of life and that
we all must face and that we can get
through it